[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
wir würden ihnen heute gerne zeichen der
entspannung senden aber wenn man die
nachrichten aus russland der ukraine und
den usa zusammen nimmt dann ist das
gegenteil der fall westliche experten
sagen das risiko eines krieges ist hoch
sie befürchten eine russische militär
invasion in der ukraine aber sie warnen
auch vor russischen cyberattacken
sabotageaktionen und des
informationskampagnen wenn man der
amerikanischen regierung glaubt dann
sind die schon konkret geplant die usa
sondieren bereits wie im notfall die
gasversorgung für europa sicherzustellen
wäre die aktuellen entwicklungen fast
jetzt thomas gonschior zusammen
moskau macht mobil verlegt truppen und
panzer richtung ukraine mehr und mehr
und zeigt das gerne der welt die ist
mehr und mehr beunruhigt pentagon und
weißes haus sagen gestern spätabends
russland bereitet ein anlass für einen
angriff vor wir haben informationen dass
russland kräfte in stellung gebracht hat
für eine fonds fleck operation im osten
der ukraine
die kämpfe haben erfahrung im
häuserkampf und mit sprengstoff für
sabotageakte in russlands eigene
verbündete
phones fleck unter falscher flagge die
operation lief in den separatisten
gebieten das prinzip russische agenten
greifen pro-russische stellungen wie
diese an ihre unterstützer also nach
außen ließe sich das als ukrainischen
angriff darstellen vorwand für moskau
das land anzugreifen geschehen könnte
das ab sofort so washington russland
dementiert heute per facebook wie üblich
gibt es keine beweise teilt die
botschaft in washington mit die
unablässigen anschuldigungen gegen uns
von den usa opfern politik oder medien
sind unbegründet russland ist gegen den
krieg
gleichwohl gab es bereits einen angriff
einen via internet die webseiten der
ukrainischen regierung gestern
lahmgelegt das außen das
katastrophenschutzministerium online
nicht erreichbar das waren russische
hacker das militär in kiew sagt dass
sich da sicher die taktik immer
destabilisierung dann starten sie eine
aktion
deeskalation sollten diese woche
gespräche mit russland bringen greifbare
ergebnisse fehlanzeige stattdessen eine
alarmierende einschätzung litauens die
gefahr eines kriegs in europa ist so
groß wie seit 1945 nicht mehr moskau
macht mobil machen die russen ernst der
westen hofft noch dass sie doch kein
feuer entzünden wollen
ja da kommt eine ganze reihe von
massiven vorwürfen gegenüber russlands
führung aus den usa und zwar direkt aus
dem weißen haus benjamin daniel in
washington abend was ist davon zu halten
wie viel eigene säbelrasseln ist
möglicherweise dabei
ich glaube in dem fall ist das schon
deutlich mehr als nur show denn die usa
die sind zum einen sehr eng vernetzt mit
dem ukrainischen geheimdienst und zum
anderen ist man generell ganz gut
aufgestellt in osteuropa was aufklärung
haben betrifft sowohl aus der luft als
auch am boden und also ich glaube dass
das kann man schon sehr ernst nehmen und
der nationale sicherheitsberater sechs
hallen der hat sich vor zwei tagen mit
ein paar journalisten hat er gesprochen
und er hat auch gar nicht groß rum
geschmuggelt er hat das relativ klar
gesagt ich zitiere mal einen satz er
sagte wir haben dieses drehbuch 2014
gesehen also er meint damit die
situation unmittelbar vor der aktion der
krim und sie bereiten dieses drehbuch
gerade wieder vor also dass das sind
schon klare worte ob putin dann am ende
tatsächlich so skrupellos wäre agenten
zu schicken die unter falscher flagge
dann pro-russische separatisten also in
an- und abführung die eigenen leute
angreifen würden so dass er ein grund
hätte im bombers einzumarschieren das
halte ich im moment für sehr schwer
einzuschätzen aber dass es mindestens
mal eine option für den kreml ist davon
geht auch hier das weiße haus ganz fest
aus der bericht aus washington von
benjamin daniel herzlichen dank
und jetzt in der sendung unser update
zur corona lage bei uns in deutschland
omikron treibt die infektionszahlen weit
nach oben jede jeder erkennt
mittlerweile ja menschen die infiziert
sind auf den intensivstationen macht
sich omikron aber derzeit nicht
bemerkbar zumindest noch nicht und auf
den straßen in gleich einer ganzen reihe
von städten heute proteste gegen korona
maßnahmen und impfpflicht und proteste
gegen diese proteste der
verfassungsschutz chef macht da eine
ganz neue szene von extremisten aus die
keine ideologische klammer verbinde
sondern die verachtung des rechtsstaats
wer genau demonstriert das ist
offensichtlich regional sehr
unterschiedlich es gab heute auch
protestzüge von denen keinerlei
aggression ausging aber viel frust und
sorge klara wiedeking beginnt ihren
überblick in sachsen wo die bisher sehr
strengen regeln jetzt etwas gelockert
werden
endlich die piste runter hier auf dem
fichtelberg im sächsischen erzgebirge
wird nach fast zwei jahren corona pause
der skibetrieb wieder aufgenommen eine
wohltat für die kleinen orte die vom
tourismus leben hier zählt jeder tag an
dem geöffnet ist das wissen auch die
politiker
ich glaube genau jetzt muss das signal
kommen die politik ist verlässlich
niedrige zahlen also es muss geöffnet
werden aber wir appellieren weiter lasst
euch impfen die zuletzt sehr strikten
regeln in sachsen könnten ein grund für
die inzwischen guten zahlen seien mit
228,7 ist die sieben tage incidents mit
die niedrigste im land der bundesweite
durchschnitt liegt bei 497,1 ein neuer
höchstwert
die ausbreitung des nikon wir es hängt
zum einen natürlich davon habt habe ich
noch maßnahmen die insgesamt virus
ausbreitung kämen also ist alles offen
oder gibt es einschränkungen krank die
menschenmassen oder tragen sie keine
masken und wie gut ist mein impfschutz
und wie gut ist der kürzlichen bloß der
schutz auch und das ist natürlich
regional unterschiedlich omikron breitet
sich von norden in der republik aus doch
trotz der rekordwerte bei den
neuinfektionen auf den intensivstationen
scheint sich die lage zu entspannen dort
geht die zahl der korona patienten
stetig zurück allerdings
wir haben jetzt hier und auch in anderen
kliniken er das problem dass viele viele
patienten sind auf der normalstation das
gleichzeitig mitarbeiter ausfallen und
das sind zwei neue probleme und wir
müssen jetzt viele kurve bereiche
schaffen in vielen norddeutschen
kliniken auf der normalstation und
einige patienten sind auch nicht krank
sondern kommen wegen anderer probleme
herzinfarkt schlaganfall und werden
zufällig dann getestet sind positiv
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
hat in einem zeitungsinterview einen
strategiewechsel in den raum gestellt
wir brauchen jetzt gerade bei nikon
einen breiteren ansatz es wird nicht
mehr ausreichen die lage nur medizinisch
und virologisch zu betrachten wir müssen
auch auf die gesellschaftliche und
soziale komponente stärker achten
und in der gesellschaft regt sich
einiges wie hier in hamburg tausende
menschen haben gegen die korona
maßnahmen protestiert obwohl die demo
wegen des infektionsschutz es verboten
worden war
erstmals kam es hier auch zu einer
größeren gegen demo gegen die impfgegner
und verschwörungs ideologen hunderte
waren angemeldet mehrere tausend sind
auf die straße gegangen
so und jetzt die nachrichtenübersicht
und daher müssen wir nochmal ganz
aktuell in die usa short ganz genau denn
in einer synagoge in colleville im
us-bundesstaat texas hat ein bewaffneter
mann offenbar mehrere geiseln genommen
dort sind kräfte der bundespolizei fbi
sowie spezialeinheiten im einsatz
polizei habe verhandlungen mit dem mann
aufgenommen so us medien
die hintergründe der geiselnahme in der
synagoge der gemeinde beth israel sind
bisher unklar
vor dem inselstaat tonga im südpazifik
ist ein unterwasser vulkan ausgebrochen
und hat in der region einen tsunami
ausgelöst
satellitenbilder zeigen das ausmass der
gigantischen aschewolke eine flutwelle
von etwa einem meter soll zahlreiche
häuser in der hauptstadt tangas
überschwemmt haben bewohner flohen in
höher gelegene gebiete berichte über
verletzte gibt es bisher nicht
arbeitgeber die die gründung von
betriebsräten behindern sollen in
zukunft schneller mit der
staatsanwaltschaft zu tun bekommen dazu
will bundesarbeitsminister heil das
strafrecht verschärfen
immer wieder würden menschen
drangsaliert wenn sie betriebsräte
gründen wollten sagte heil der
augsburger allgemeinen zeitung das ist
zwar schon jetzt verboten allerdings
wird nur auf antrag ermittelt künftig
solle schon ausreichen dass eine
strafverfolgungsbehörde kenntnis davon
bekommt
nach den starken verlusten der linken
bei der bundestagswahl ging es beim
digitalen jahresauftakt der partie heute
um aufarbeitung und neuanfang in einem
strategiepapier fordert die linke eine
schnellere klima wende bis 2030 soll der
kohleausstieg abgeschlossen sein und
bereits 2035 soll deutschland
klimaneutral wirtschaften also zehn
jahre früher als von der bundesregierung
geplant
in afghanistan steht die internationale
gemeinschaft vor einem dilemma nicht
erst seit heute aber aktuell noch mal
ganz besonders drängend die
vermögenswerte des landes sind seit der
machtübernahme der taliban blockiert
afghanistan ist vom internationalen
zahlungsverkehr abgeschnitten
überweisungen kommen nicht durch bargeld
ist mangelware das sollte das taliban
regime treffen es trifft alle so sehr
dass die uno jetzt alarm schlägt
eingefrorenes vermögen und eisige
temperaturen sind eine tödliche
kombination sagt der generalsekretär
katrin eigendorf berichtet es ist
bitterkalt in der nacht sinken die
temperaturen auf minus grade der erste
winter seitdem die taliban die macht
ergriffen haben droht zum grausamsten
der vergangenen 20 jahre zu werden im
sommer waren die lebensmittel schon
knapp geworden jetzt kommt's zum hunger
auch noch die kälte auf dem hof seines
leben hauses das er vor acht jahren
selbst gebaut hat kämpft kanada gegen
den schnee der dreijährige karim hat
nicht einmal feste schuhe sein jüngster
ist noch ein baby
als es letztens geschneit hat kam das
wasser durch die decke unser nachbar hat
es gesehen und uns 200 afghani geliehen
für plastik um die fenster abzudecken
das ist unsere lage an einem tag haben
wir etwas zu essen am nächsten tag nicht
was sollen wir tun es gibt keine lösung
immer öfter müssen sie entscheiden
lebensmittel oder holz hunger oder kälte
aga khans 52 jährige mutter die mit
ihnen im haus lebt traut sich nur noch
selten heraus und muss ihren
zehnjährigen sohn auf die straße
schicken
vorher war unsere situation besser jetzt
haben wir nichts zu essen die kinder
sind hungrig eines meiner kinder
verkauft plastiktüten auf der straße das
ist alles was wir verdienen mit den
taliban kämpfern die kabul vor genau
fünf monaten erobert hatten ist die
angst und die note für viele menschen
zum alltag geworden frauen die sich nur
noch streng verhüllt heraus trauen
männer die vergeblich auf arbeit hoffen
in der verteilung stelle des world food
program werden mehl und öl ausgegeben
nothilfe 23 millionen menschen leiden
hunger ein drama dass auch routinierte
helfer schockiert und überfordert
der mangel an essen und der hunger ist
beängstigend wir hatten familien in
kabul und auch in einigen provinzen die
sind gestorben weil sie über wochen
hunger litten
welche perspektive gibt es noch für
kanada und seine familie der 32 jährige
wirkt verzweifelt
zerfressen von sorgen wie lange kann das
noch gut gehen
ich bin tagelöhner ich gehe durch die
stadt aber dort gibt es keine jobs mehr
für uns ich versuche wirklich alles aber
die wirtschaftliche lage ist sehr
schlecht
das land drohe in diesem winter von
einer lawine von hunger und elend
überrollt zu werden man
hilfsorganisationen nur wenige monate
nach dem abzug der internationalen
truppen ist afghanistan zum schlimmsten
krisenherd weltweit geworden
sie können den menschen in afghanistan
mit einer spende helfen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
dafür ein konto eingerichtet
das ist die bahn de 6 5 104 106 100 104
106 100 das stichwort zdf nothilfe
afghanistan weitere informationen im
internet auf spenden zdf de und dem zdf
text auf seite 8 190 und jetzt hier in
der sendung hat hanna noch den sport im
blick
drei anläufe haben sie gebraucht in
diesem winter jetzt hat es die deutsche
biathlon-staffel aufs podest geschafft
beim weltcup in ruhpolding erkämpfte
sich das männer quartett hinter russland
den zweiten platz und am schießstand
waren die deutschen herren heute sogar
die besten all das gibt selbstvertrauen
drei wochen vor beginn der olympischen
winterspiele in peking
und nun die lottozahlen die lauten 5 34
42 43 48 49 und die superzahl 9 alle
angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
und jetzt noch ein ausblick und zwar
aufs wetter
morgen scheint vom schwarzwald bis nach
oberbayern oft die sonne am vormittag
zeigt sie sich auch in sachsen ansonsten
ist es trüb mit sprühregen bei einem
lebhaften an der küste stürmischem
westwind werden minus eins bis plus acht
grad erreicht
am montag gibt es schnee regen und
stürmischen sind im osten am dienstag
bleibt es trocken am mittwoch kommt im
norden neuer regen auf bei den
temperaturen ändert sich nur wenig
oha ziemlich kalt das ganze wichtiges
fernseh wetter auf jeden fall ihr beide
sagen im namen des gesamten
heute-journal teams danke für das
interesse und ein schön ab noch
[Musik]